I'm in Syracuse with my assistant Roberta and apparently most of Syracuse as well.
We were going to do the experiment we've been learning about--Eratosthenes' experiment
where he determines the circumference of the earth measuring shadows.
All you're going to need to do to perform this experiment is get some help.
Thank you Roberta. >>You're welcome.
You're going need a string or some sort of straight stick, a weight on the end of that string
to make sure that it's truly vertical and some sort of measuring device.
Now my measuring device is a ruler and it's marked in inches.
You might have one marked in centimeters, but like we mentioned before
the only thing relevant in this experiment is the ratio and the units don't matter.
It's really not important. Now let's go ahead and make our first measurement.
Can you just put it this way--perfect--and down so your thumb touches it--perfect, perfect.
And the length here is 42 inches. Now without changing anything, without moving anything.
Rebecca is holding perfectly still. Gracia!
I'm going to make the next measurement which is that of the shadow
and I get a result of 8-1/2 inches.
Now you'll notice over here, it's not really clear where the shadow begins and ends.
This is uncertainty in my measurement and that's something we're going to have to deal with.
When you do the experiment at home, you'll have uncertainty as well.
In fact, uncertainty is inherit to any measurement you make in physics.
We'll talk about that later but thank you very much Rebecca. >>You're welcome.